can you believe how long you've been
with the view you're now almost in the
territory
of being on the view longer than barbara
walters
you know because i think you're such a
fabulous actress i figured you would
have said is this
really what i want to be doing sitting
here with these hunters day in and day
out
i'm a talented powerhouse actress you
are
there's no question you can get the job
done ghost
masterful yeah color purple masterful
your stage stuff that you did when you
first came on the scene
masterful you're a master at this art
and when you're a master you should be
doing
what you do so well you have to have
people asking you to master things
listen i have uh the stand coming up
right i did the stand
last year and it's kind of fabulous and
i love stephen king and
you know things come up and i think
my time has been spread
you know it's not that my time will come
back it's not gone anywhere
it's just still there and i guess i'm
supposed to be doing this
right now i guess i'm supposed to be in
this
chair every day saying
listen we do not have to buy into fear
or panic
we can master this if we do it together
i
feel like i'm better off
saying listen somebody needs to stand up
when the person in the white house says
hey maybe we should inject
some bleach i'm the person that has to
say hey
hey you sitting there you need to stand
up and say you can't do no
no so i feel like there's stuff i'm
supposed to be doing but yeah sure i'd
like to be making a movie and i'm sure i
will again